Yuriko the Tiger’s Shadow is a pretty unique card.
It’s the most popular Dimir commander by a country
mile. It’s one of only two creature-type-based
commanders that sees common cEDH play, the other
being Magda of course. And, Yuriko does not pay
commander tax. I guess if you’re casting her for
her base cost she does, but more realistically
Yuriko almost always gets cast for a Commander
Ninjutsu cost, which is forever pegged at 2
mana. Last week I talked about Eminence as one
of the two major exceptions to the way commanders
work, not even requiring a commander to be on the
board to have an initial effect, and this is the
other—not costing additional mana for subsequent
commander casts. Yuriko in particular has been
singled out as a design mistake, including by
Gavin Verhey who worked on the original card,
and I agree with that. Commander-ninjutsu is
this bespoke ability created with the one
task of bringing ninjutsu into the command
zone on a single, and the fact that command
tax wasn’t a part of that ability seems like
an obvious oversight in retrospect. The results
of this have bled into the player experience,
with Yuriko commanding a similar salt score to
that of Edgar Markov, the most contentious of
the Eminence commanders. People are bothered by
this card, and they dread playing against it.
However, I think it’s interesting to dig into why
Yuriko is a problem for people, and how important
her tax evasion is in that equation. Because
I think the line for not paying command tax
is actually blurrier than it seems, and more
sensitive to the specifics of a given card,
with Yuriko’s other features being equally
important as her unique method of entry in
creating her infamous status. Broadly, there are
two things that contribute to Yuriko in particular
having a uniquely frustrating play pattern for
a lot of players—her vibes, and her power level.
By vibes I mean that the way Yuriko cheats
commander tax feels uniquely bad among commanders,
and to demonstrate that we should talk about some
other tax evaders, and why they don’t drum up the
same sort of ire. Firstly, let’s talk about
the Squees of the world, legendary creatures
that can be cast from graveyard. On the surface,
these may seem similar to something like Yuriko
since you can continue to cast them for some
fixed cost after they die, but the comparison
quickly falls apart. Firstly, all but one of
them will be whisked back to the command zone by
any now-commonplace exile-based removal, but more
importantly, they obey the rules of 60 card magic.
These cards are designed with the idea of them
being cast over and over baked into the design,
and their function in a 60 card format will
be identical to their function in commander
after the first cast. The uniquely potent
thing about Commander is the command zone,
and these are skipping out on a large portion
of the benefit of that zone. One step up from
these would be Hogaak, a commander with the two
different discount keywords of convoke and delve.
Hogaak also shares being castable from the
graveyard, but perhaps more relevantly, regardless
of where the card is being cast from you won’t be
spending mana. If it gets exiled a couple times,
the command zone cost will go up accordingly, but
paying in exiles from graveyard or tapped creature
tokens will often feel much less meaningful than
paying in mana—you won’t experience paying for
Hogaak as a linear barrier in the same way you
would with most other commanders. Nonetheless,
Hogaak feels fine because itspayment method still
performs the gesture of paying command tax. A big
part of what makes Yuriko frustrating is that it
feels like the Yuriko player is exempted from a
core rule of the commander format—when other
commanders get removed, they’re harder to cast,
but Yuriko simply isn’t. Even if Hogaak
bucks some of the conventional wisdom,
it doesn’t feel like a major outlier because
you’re still expending additional resources.
This idea comes into even sharper focus when
we consider Liesa. Liesa, Shroud of Dusk is
a 5 mana commander who, instead of requiring
2 more mana for each subsequent command zone
cast, instead requires paying 2 life for each
previous cast. As a Liesa player I will tell
you right now, that is not a meaningful
cost. In the 40 life format of commander,
most players are plenty willing to fork
over 3 life in exchange for one mana,
and 2 life for one mana, as seen in something like
a Phyrexian mana symbol or an untapped shockland,
is pretty much a no brainer. Cutting that
no-brainer rate in half, 1 life for 1 mana,
makes it basically free and will rarely feel even
a little bit relevant. So, why doesn’t Liesa come
to mind as a chronic tax evader? The answer, along
with other factors we’ll get to later, is The
Gesture. If my Liesa dies, when I cast her again,
I adjust my life total die down two numbers. If I
need to cast her again after that, four numbers.
It’s not significant, but it’s something,
an acknowledgement that my commander has died and
this is not the first time I’m casting her. I’m
not playing by the exact same rules as everybody
else, but I’m still playing the same format,
and I recognize the existence of that format’s
rules. This brings me to an example that, while
less problematic than Yuriko, is a bit hairier
than the ones I’ve mentioned so far—Derevi.
She is a 3 mana bant commander with the ability
to pay 4 mana to put her from the command zone
into play at instant speed. This ability doesn’t
perform the gesture, and it does kinda totally
cheat command tax. So… what makes this different
from Yuriko? This is where the details get more
granular from a purely costs perspective. You
could argue that 4 mana is larger than 3 mana,
so Derevi’s cost will usually go up at least
once, though it’s not hard to imagine somebody
arguing that flash and uncounterability mitigates
this difference, making the 4 mana cast option an
appealing one in its own right. To me, the
more potent element is the raw number—4 is
a lot more than 2. Paying 2 mana for a commander
repeatedly is quite inherently powerful. You hit
the field early, and then subsequent plays will
leave boatloads of open mana for follow-up plays
or counterspells or so on. By contrast, paying 4
mana repeatedly for Derevi or 5 mana repeatedly
for Liesa feels more meaningful as a cost. It’s
still quite nice to have spare mana later in the
game when you’re on 7 or 8 lands and not needing
to worry about having an uncastably expensive
commander, but that dynamic exists on a decidedly
lesser caliber than something like Yuriko.
So far I’ve been ignoring the text boxes
of all the cards I’ve been talking about,
which has its upsides in isolating
specific design elements. However,
now it’s time to talk about the other reason
Yuriko feels so frustrating—the power level.
What I mean by power level here is simply how much
power you get based on the amount of mana you pay.
Yuriko’s text box does such a large amount for
2 mana that it’s almost absurd. The actual text
reads “Whenever a ninja you control deals combat
damage to a player, reveal the top card of your
library and put it into your hand. Each opponent
loses life equal to that card’s mana value.”
If we wanted to grossly simplify this,
we could replace this with the text:
whenever a ninja you control deals combat damage
to a player, draw a card and each opponent loses
2 life. Trying to find an equivalent card led to
Seshiro the Anointed, a 6 mana snakes commander
who could realistically be more like 4 mana
given the niche position of snakes, and Tovolar,
a 3 mana wolf and werewolf commander with a bit
of added utility for flipping werewolves but no
equivalent damage ability. And Tovolar is a pretty
good typal commander, a whole lot of tribes would
swoon at receiving that level of utility from
the command zone. So we’ll say that Yuriko is
along the lines of a powerful 3 mana commander or
a moderately-powered 4 mana commander, and it’s
castable for 2 mana as many times as you like as
long as you’re able to pay the ninjutsu cost. So,
how hard is that? Well, a quick visit to the
Yuriko EDHREC page makes that clear. Ornithopter
exists as an evasive 0-cost creature that can
get Yuriko into play, and there are a ton of
great evasive 1 mana creatures that can do the
same. Thousand-faced Shadow, Changeling Outcast,
and Mothdust Changeling are all also Ninjas,
and there are other cards like Faerie Seer,
Siren Stormtamer, and Hope of Ghirapur that
have meaningful other upside with Yuriko’s
gameplan. It decidedly is a cost, but given
that other Ninjutsu creatures can make use
of these evasive little doofuses as well,
it’s hard to call it too dramatic a cost.
By comparison, Derevi’s untapping
effect for 3ish mana is far from bad,
but it doesn’t give direct value or direct damage,
unlike Yuriko which gives both for 2-3 mana.
Derevi is a good commander and you can do a lot of
things with her, but they require the convergence
of other elements of your deck, and it’s perfectly
possible to stall out even if Derevi is generating
you a lot of mana. The power level point comes
into even sharper focus when we consider Liesa,
whose ability drains a player for 2 life whenever
they cast a spell. An equivalent effect is on
a fairly-costed 3 mana red enchantment called
Spellshock, so for two extra mana we’re slapping
that on a 5/5 angel with a couple keywords.
The result is… fine. It’s okay, an adequate
overall package, and Liesa commands a relatively
modest salt score of 0.8, even as a Group Slug
commander that effectively cheats command tax.
One interesting exercise might be to imagine a
world in which Liesa drains opponents for 4, or
even 5 whenever they cast a spell instead. That
design wouldn’t be overpowered beyond the realm
of possibility, but it would be pushing toward
the upper reaches of what you might want to put
on a 5 mana card, and for that reason I think that
version of Liesa would be absolutely despised, a
monstrous commander that players shudder in fear
thinking about. Barring counterspells, best case
scenario here is your opponent slams this down,
you spend 5 life and some mana to remove it, and
they spend some life to bring it back out again
the following turn without any commander tax.
Nauseating stuff! Obviously this is more of a
hardcore group slug design, but nevertheless this
is the sort of power territory Yuriko lives in.
We could alternatively imagine if Yuriko had a
commander ninjutsu cost of 4, with everything
else about the card remaining the same. It would
remain a fairly decent ninjas commander, still a
more powerful card than Liesa, but it would lose
its status as an unstoppable freight train of
damage and value, instead being costed similarly
to a Coastal Piracy, plus a creature bounce.
This elucidates a weird quirk of the commander
format—although it’s a casual format where
power is modulated by social factors and rule 0
tools such as the bracket system, power is still
strongly felt in how upsetting a card design is. A
lot of designs that are unobjectionable now would
become extremely objectionable with a single
tweak, a la 5 Liesa, and plenty of currently
objectionable designs would suddenly cease to be
problems at all with a nerf to their power level.
This power relationship can also be seen in
the Salt Scores that are compiled by EDHREC
by asking players how much they’re bothered by
various cards, which I’ve already referenced a
couple times in this video. The first couple dozen
saltiest cards all have some clear gameplay reason
for bothering opponents, but what about Gaea’s
Cradle? What about Necropotence? What about
Mana Vault, or The Great Henge, or Roaming
Throne? These cards are purely proactive,
and none of them do anything that unique, but they
just so happen to be at the highest power level
among all equivalent options, so they end up high
in the salt charts regardless. This relates to
fairness—even in a casual format, there might be a
sense of something an opponent does being unfair,
outside the bounds of ideal gameplay. I’m not
immune from this either—I dislike the design of
Rhystic Study in commander intrinsically
for a lot of reasons that I’ll probably
get into in a future video, and I also dislike
playing against it. Relevant to the point here,
would I dislike Rhystic Study less if it was
a 5 mana card rather than a 3 mana one? Yeah,
I would. It wouldn’t solve my core gripes with
the card, but it would bother me less if it
cost more mana. We can kind of see how this
concept of fairness applies to Yuriko—a full
command tax cheater will garner some baseline
level of frustration from opponents, and that
frustration will then be amplified depending
on the power level of the card it lives on.
So, what does this all mean for the future? Should
Wizards of the Coast avoid cards with alternative
command tax structures, or should they print more
of them? My attitude here shares some similarities
with my attitude about Eminence cards, in the
sense that they’re both motivated by a sense of
curiosity and a spirit of play. I like it when
the mechanics of EDH format are tinkered with,
utilized, and recontextualized in ways that make
for interesting gameplay. I enjoy designs that
reference commanders and involve the number
of times a commander has been cast from the
command zone, both on commanders themselves and
on supporting cards. I also like alternative
costs like the ones I’ve discussed earlier, and
ways of interacting with command tax in some way.
This choice of wording may hint at the line I
draw, though, and that’s that commanders need
to make The Gesture: they need to acknowledge,
in some form or other, that they exist within
a format where your commander costs more
each time it’s redeployed. Hogaak and Liesa
both make the gesture, even if their command
tax feels insignificant at times. Partners
make The Gesture—some will argue it’s unfair
that each partner has a separate command tax,
but how they work with command tax is
still an acknowledgement of the mechanic,
and is one interpretation of how it could
function with two commanders. On the other hand,
a big part of the reason Derevi and especially
Yuriko are commonly disliked commanders is that
they don’t make The Gesture. Their design totally
ignores the existence of command tax, and if you
play either of these you don’t even really need
to learn what command tax is. My reasoning for
why commanders should acknowledge the existence
of command tax in some form is similar to the
reasons why I think Eminence commanders should
feel incomplete if they go uncast—flirting with
the mechanical borders of the commander format is
a lovely time, but it creates a weird dynamic if
the design you end up with feels totally outside
those borders. It creates an unfair feeling when
three players are following a set of rules
that the other player is totally exempt from.
So that’s one half of my design philosophy here,
and the other half is that for cards like Liesa or
Tasigur that make the gesture but frequently
feel inconsequential in their casting cost,
it’s important to keep in mind how the card will
feel with 100% uptime. The current delve-boys,
Tasigur and Hogaak, feel fine in this way,
with their most powerful usages involving
their mana value rather than what they do if they
stick around on board. Liesa is likewise fine,
if anything a bit modest in terms of power
level. The point here is just that cards that
are easier than normal to redeploy need
to keep that in mind with their design,
and that relates to both power level and play
pattern. If a commander is disgustingly powerful,
it’s going to feel especially unpleasant if
it’s difficult to keep off the board. Likewise,
if a card is oppressive in some way, making
it hard for some other decks to play the game,
the feelings of powerlessness it imbues onto those
decks will be amplified when conventional methods
of dealing with the commander don’t work very
well. I’ve enjoyed the feeling that my opponents
can’t escape Liesa when I’ve played with her in
the past, and that is a fun vibe to toy with,
but it really only works because her effect
puts a small tax on a plentiful resource,
and it’s up to me to try and make that plentiful
resource scarce. It makes it a little harder
for me to critique Wizards of the Coast when the
biggest instance of a de-facto command tax cheater
is actually a really good design, but oh well.
Be more like Liesa is what I’m saying, I guess.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt for
supporting the channel. In preparation for an
upcoming event I’ve done some light upgrading to
my Malfegor and Breena decks and some sidegrading
to my Radha deck, and it was easy to keep things
organized with Archidekt’s dual-level category
system. A link to my decks is in the description
if you wanna take a look at some of the tweaks
I’ve made. Speaking of upcoming events, I’m
going to be at LDXP Tacoma this coming weekend,
both enjoying Commandfest and hopefully playing a
bit of Riftbound as well. Most of the convention
is available to attend for free, and I hope
to see you there. If you want to support what
I do on this channel, you can become a YouTube
member or subscribe to my Patreon, and you’ll
be joining the lovely people you see on screen
now and more. Alright, that’s all for this one.